foreign
bomber targets a political conference in
Northwest Pakistan
where hundreds of supporters of the
jamaic Islam Fazal party were meeting
I don't know how and what exactly
happened I just saw a spark and had a
big bang I was sitting close to the
stage and our leadership was nearby
after the blast I saw hundreds of people
lying on the ground and people started
firing in the air
dozens of people were killed and
hundreds injured some were airlifted to
the provincial capital per shower for
treatment but most were taken to the
city's main hospital
most of our wounded are in serious
condition my request to the governor and
the administration Peshawar is that they
should make arrangements to treat these
patients well also I appeal to our party
workers to go to the hospital for blood
donation
the jail District near the Afghan border
was once a stronghold of the Pakistani
Taliban before the Army drove them out
the area Jimmy atelama Islam has
ideological ties with the Pakistani
Taliban analysts say that's likely to be
the reason the group was targeted I do
think it's likely that Islamic State
correspond the Pakistan Afghanistan
branch of Islamic State was behind this
attack and the reason I say that is that
indeed this Islamic state has targeted
the guif political party in the past in
great part because the guif has or some
of its leaders at least have expressed
support for the Taliban and Islamic
State corus on his arrival of the
Taliban
leaders of jamaic Islam say this attack
was an attempt to intimidate supporters
ahead of parliamentary elections in
November Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera
well Kamala Haider is live in bajore
kamau you're at the site of the blast so
tell us first what you've learned and
also I understand you're with a
counter-terrorism official we will be
very interested to hear what he has to
say come on over to you
absolutely right now I'm standing inside
the tent which is where the attack took
place there was about 400 party workers
from the Jamaica Islam they were present
here at the time a suicide bomber
penetrated the the convention and blew
himself up now this uh place has seen a
considerable rise in the number of
Terror attacks and we have now with us
the head of the counter-terrorism
department soccer the boss
first of all sir tell us there's been a
spike a number of attacks an increasing
number of attacks what is the reason for
that
uh
it's uh it's it's not corrected there's
been a spike in the incidence it's
happening for the last two months they
will Spike there was a lull period
between January and and I must say June
there was a lull period or June July I
have put this a little bit of rise at
the uh incidence of terrorism in this
part of the world
terrorism is basically
is happening because of the combination
of internal and external factors
especially in this part of this country
which is adjacent to a debris country
what's happening across the border is
very relevant over here
the something which happens across the
border has has a triggering effect over
certain events over here it's a history
it's a history spread over decades the
history is history is you know dictating
a lot of things over here
so it cannot be said very simply that
there was one factor which is triggering
these kind of incidents the multiple
factors internal external which are
collectively causing these kind of
incidents there is a suspicion that dice
may be involved in this particular
attack do you have any evidence to
suggest that that is indeed the fact
this
game of terrorism
we have recently arrested one of the
gangs in Tushar there could be a
possibility of the involvement over here
so far we've been working on it but it
will be premature to say anything
conclusively about them but we're
working on it
well that was the head of the
counter-terrorism department now it must
be understood as you saw in Victoria
gatenby's report a budget word is very
close to the Avalon border it straddles
the province of kuna just about 10
kilometers aerial distance and also
worth mentioning that after the U.S led
invasion of Afghanistan after the
September 11th attacks Al-Qaeda also
found a safe haven here this was the
epicenter of the tarika Taliban Pakistan
in 2006 the United States carried out a
bombing rate in which Emerald zawahiri
the number two leader of the al-Qaeda
who took over after Osama Bin Laden was
killed I had a narrow Escape in the
mountains of domadora which is not very
far from here so according to the
counterter terrorism Department it is
too early however we've been speaking to
a number of people who said that they
are deep suspicions that daesh carried
out this deadly attack come on look
thank you very much for all that context
and it does shed light on some of the
answers that your guest was giving you
when he said that 20 years of history in
Afghanistan or or a significant factor
in what just happened thank you very
much Kamal